James while you wait whose idea was the
cat's moment
[Applause]
as cast members of the motion picture
cats
nobody more than us understands the
importance of good visual effects yeah I
got this email thing what I like to give
on out and I thought well I think you
know who would I'd like to do with us
I'm gonna do it with rebel and could we
do address as cats they said yes and
credit to the brilliant wardrobe team at
the Oscars who really made all those
costumes those two cautions and did it
wonderfully with you know a weeks notice
so it was fun highlights of the night I
was like highlights mm Brad winning and
hats was number one on my list right I
thought it was the best moment of the
night it was so funny
have you been hanging out with Brad Pitt
tonight at the Oscars Harvey's never
been lucky enough to be in his orbit you
know so it's clear that the Oscars need
a host 2020 was good oh I think that's
not something I would ever have to think
about I don't imagine that call would
ever come my way do you think of Elton
winning tonight all right it's wonderful
it's terrific
I'm Bernie the two of them together what
a wonderful thing it was so yeah I was I
was thrilled for him as everybody
[Music]